has been a wild night we want to take
you back to that sequence earlier in the
quarter when gobert was hit with the
technical granted was Kyle Anderson who
tried to calm him down remember it was
those two that got into the altercation
last week the punch from gobert leading
to the team impose suspension really
like to see that for Chris French in
Minnesota well news flash to everybody
watching at home fights happen on teams
on good teams that's normal they don't
normally happen in a game on the bench
but both these guys understand the
opportunity here with this ball Club
I'm willing to put look past that trying
to get this win steal this win for this
ball Club